if you currently only read only one book
at a time you seriously need to stop
that right now I have read thousands of
books in my life and out of all the
experiments that I've run with my
reading being able to effectively read
multiple books in parallel is one that
has allowed me to read so much more so
much better and so much faster now as
someone who used to have a strong
emotional almost moral conviction that
it was absolutely unacceptable to start
a second book without finishing my first
I now believe that being able to
overcome the emotional and mental
barriers that I had towards this and be
able to effectively read multiple books
at once is an absolute superpower when
it comes to effective learning and also
having a genuinely enjoyable and
self-sustaining reading habits if you're
like old me and think I'm completely
insane please hear me out because this
might actually change reading for you
let's get straight into how to train
your emotional and rational brain to
read a lot at once now firstly I'm going
to talk about training our emotional
brain the reason I call this the
emotional brain is that very often the
barriers that I used to have to my
reading look something like I'm not in
the mood for reading or I don't feel
like it when I think what this actually
can also be translated to is that I
don't feel like reading this book right
now and then if we only have one option
or one book we end up never reading at
all lots of the people that want to read
more and ask me things are almost always
in the middle or in the beginning of a
book that they started last week last
month or 10 years ago that they just
never finished and they never felt like
going back to lufthan who was one of the
most prolific writers and creators ever
when he was asked how he managed to do
so much and didn't he burn out and want
to throw away his manuscripts what he
said was yes if he ever ran into a wall
he would just work on a different
project because he realized that there's
no point in kind of pushing through into
creative or learning work but rather
switching to something else and if he
can do this for writing I surely thought
I should try this with reading and it
definitely works instead of Reinventing
how much I love or hate reading
depending on the book that I'm currently
on and on my mood at the time I just
accept that my mood fluctuates
constantly and sometimes I'm just not in
the mood for reading that specific thing
and I know that this is not just me
because there is a whole host of studies
that show that even throughout a single
day on average there is a huge
fluctuation in our mood and sometimes
I'm an Elizabeth who has more or less
energy who's more melancholic or less
focused or more sad or more happy and
those kind of wavelengths emotions and
needs are things that I try to fill with
specific books rather than Plastering
the same book on every single time this
also encourages me to take more of an
emotional approach when it comes to
books and see depending on how difficult
the language is or depending on if it's
fiction or non-fiction what's the best
version of me that can show up for the
book and I think of a two-way emotional
connection with it am I in the mood for
this book and what mood will this book
put me in and as I become more in touch
with my emotional self and with the
emotions in books I am showing up as the
more interested and motivated version of
myself and as a huge fan of motivation I
know that this means that I'm a lot more
focused a lot quicker a lot more
effective and creative in taking in
information and enjoying the experience
rather than powering through something
feeling forced to do it feeling silly
and slow and disinterested which then
therefore can lead to this background
thing brewing in my brain that maybe I'm
just a bad reader or I just don't enjoy
doing this thing this emotional
enjoyment and connection with books is
something that I take one step further
by adopting something from people who
follow religion and perhaps this might
be one slight way to convince you to
read a second book if you still strongly
believe that it should only be one at a
time I really really adore how people
who read things like the Bible or the
Quran will read them almost every day or
every week and they will read these
things repetitively so it kind of
creates this safe space and this thing
that you can escape to and kind of take
in every time that you need it and
improve the overall quality of your life
as Pascal also said you should always
keep something beautiful in your mind
because it helps you deal with the
bleakness of reality now I don't want to
call all reality Bleak but I do think
that there is a huge benefit in
realizing that we have this book and it
might even be a fairy tale from when we
were younger or a fictional story that
we adored from school but anything that
just creates this beautiful space of
escapism for us that we can just leave
as a background book that we play on
repeats again and again and again a book
that this year I go through all the time
at least once a week is the untethered
soul and this is a book which I've
reread so many times but it kind of
really calms me down when I'm very
anxious or over stimulated or I just
want to relax afternet winter is inside
to be ill adjusted to a deranged world
is not a breakdown and as funny as it is
I think we all have a requirement for
some grounding and books can really
provide a strong thing for us some
science to this this is what huberman
would call a linchpin Behavior which is
basically creating positive associations
with something which then allows us to
want to do more of it so if we have just
one book that we adore and we are
reading always in the background it
makes it more likely for us to pick a
different book and to slowly fall back
in love with reading again now I'm
moving on to the second point which is
training our rational brain and I
believe this is where a lot of the
issues come in what I hear a lot and
what I used to firmly believe is that we
don't do a book Justice if we are
reading it alongside something else that
I will obviously forget where I've left
things off and I'm not going to be as
focused and that I'm never going to
finish anything and it just dilutes my
experience and my attention and I think
this can happen but it also can
definitely be avoided and I'm going to
try and tell you how I do this
effectively so when we were back in
school for example we used to read a lot
of books at the same time so I had a
Biology book a chemistry book a physics
book a maths book and these were
effectively I could remember where I
left off I never thought maths was
biology or vice versa and I think this
is something that I do when I read
multiple books now I don't mix genres
and what that means is that even though
I technically can read sometimes 10 or
12 books at a time I don't really read
two fictional romantic stories at once
because I want to mix them with one
another now I'm going to show what this
specifically looks like for me but
before I do that I just want to mention
girls law which basically states that
every complex system also evolved from a
simple system that worked so basically
I'm not recommending that you go from
one book to all of this but that's
slowly adding one book at a time can
lead you here basically I'm almost
always reading one good new fiction book
one bad new fiction book one good old
fiction book one one non-fiction book
which is good one non-fiction book which
is bad good philosophy book one bad
philosophy but one interesting science
book which may be old or new some
background book which is kind of for my
soul or to keep me happy and grounded
and I might have one or two books which
may be in any genre that have just been
recommended from other people for me to
read and this is kind of all of the
things in my potential library and what
I do is depending on my mood or what I'm
feeling like at the moment I might just
pick one out of them in my personal
mental categorization there's no overlap
here actually and I can very
distinctively imagine what these books
are and the categories they fall into so
they don't technically interact with one
another in such a way that I would no
longer understand a book or that would
be damaging and whatever this
categorization looks like you depending
on the types of books that you read you
can also create something personal that
looks like this and then what this does
is that at any given time I'm
potentially in the mood to read one of
these things another extra letter that I
add to this distinctiveness is to read
them in different ways is so just by
virtue of the fact that some of these
books I need to take more notes on or
less notes on or that I want to read
when I'm traveling or when I'm late in
bed at night and I don't want two strong
lights I tend to use five different ways
of reading which are physical books
which is also my favorite audiobooks I
can read on my iPad or on my laptop or
on my Kindle and because these are also
connected to different sources I then
also kind of attach the book to the
physical thing that I'm using with it so
then I can effectively distinguish them
from one another what's very important
for the rational brain is a huge benefit
that I find when I'm reading multiple
books at once and this is that I get
very very creative and I have a lot more
context and richness in the storytelling
or in the scientific content of the book
If I mix them with one another so for
example at the moment I am randomly
reading two different books one is on
morality and one is on the stress of
eating and for whatever reason because I
read them both in one day I kind of
created a much closer connection with
these books that wasn't necessarily
there so for example I am thinking of
Morality In terms of food morality but
I'm also thinking of the ethics of our
food industry so this kind of
combination adds a huge layer of
richness and a lot more creativity to
the books that wasn't within them
themselves and I often find when I'm
cross-matching books in this way I can
think of the philosophy of the behavior
of the characters or I can think of the
morals in physics where I can think of
kind of the ethics in poetry so this
sort of cross combination means that I
am approaching these books with a lot
more enrichment and this really really
helps establish my learning in a way
that is so so powerful not only does it
lay memories and connect books very
effectively together but also means that
I am seeing these books in a very unique
way and I have a lot more commentary or
thoughts or feelings about them than I
would have had if I was reading them in
isolation and I find this to be such a
powerful way to learn more and to get
more from the books that I'm reading I
think if I wanted to be I could be very
intentional I'd read two books at the
same time almost intentionally I don't
do this I just randomize and do whatever
I feel like reading but I think that
this is super super effective and a huge
area of potential if someone wants to
look into this more as well store said
humans probe the cause of things even if
there are none and as I'm reading I like
to take cause and effect from one book
to the other and really enrich my mental
experience and my learning that comes
with them and I think that this is
something that I was definitely missing
when I was reading one book at a time my
last training for effectively reading
multiple books or reading in general is
something that I've only accepted very
recently and this is the fact that there
are certain things that I don't memorize
and there are certain things that I do
memorize so I'm really really bad with
names and quotes and specific words but
I'm really really interested and curious
and I can memorize things like Concepts
and Frameworks and thoughts and
different sorts of creative processes so
I fully accepted that I'm completely out
sourcing my memorization so I
highlighted also books and underlined
lots of books and I have a full video
that I kind of go into detail my quite
simple method actually for taking notes
effectively from books but this is
something that I do very very
guiltlessly because I know there's no
chance that I will remember this it
didn't happen when I've read one book at
a time it definitely doesn't happen
where I read multiple books at a time
but the Frameworks are things that I can
fully kind of integrate and learn a lot
better it's very important to draw a
line between what we can and cannot
memorize and I'm constantly testing my
limits with trying to memorize more read
more read less slower and faster and I
feel that this approach is a lot more
effective to find your Optimum whatever
that looks like lastly if you made it so
far and you're also interested in
optimizing things and learning and
becoming better I really want to thank
the sponsor of this video 80 000 hours
which have absolutely nothing to sell
you but everything to teach you very
interestingly 80 000 hours is a book
that I summarized and commented on way
before I even had a YouTube channel back
on my website back in the day basically
what this is is a book a newsletter a
podcast cost of a bunch of research from
Oxford University which looks into what
are the best ways for us to spend our
life and spend our time so basically
they've asked me to ask you if this is
something that you're interested in
everything that they do is always going
to be free I would really recommend
downloading the book as I did back in
the day it's really really insightful
and looking into there are different
resources and seeing what are the best
ways to make the world a better place
for ourselves and for the future and how
to spend our life in the meantime so if
you're unsure what to do with your life
or with the 80 000 hours of working job
time that we have there's going to be a
link in my description which will send
you kind of a career guide or some
thoughts and prompts around what to do
with yourself so I would really
recommend checking that out if you want
to otherwise thank you so much for
making it with me so far I hope you have
a wonderful rest of your day be count
yourself and others and don't believe
everything you think thanks bye